You look at an animation show,
like a show
like a Cartoon Network and Adult Swim.
It takes the network about anywhere
between 500 to $700,000
per episode to produce,
and it takes a very long time.
Amit Tishler, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Finally, it's an honor to have you.
Yeah. Thank you so much.
Happy to be here.
Animations, graphic design,
technology startups, gaming, you know,
we have so much to talk about
because I know nothing
about the work, the fascinating work
that you're doing.
Amit, first of all, who are you?
Because you're not just
the typical entrepreneur, are you?
Probably not.
The question, "Who are you?",
like man, that is a big one.
Am I really the one to define that?
It's philosophical.
Well, okay, let me try
and summarize the weird history
of my life, I suppose, or my career.
Please.
So, I actually started I think,
like you said, I'm not exactly
the boilerplate entrepreneur
in terms of my story
and my career progression.
I started off from a 2D animation.
So, I studied hand drawing animation.
We're talking light tables, pencils.
That was the first medium
I've ever practiced in.
And I studied in Israel.
I'm originally from Tel Aviv.
I guess in that regard,
I am kind of like fitting
within the entrepreneur box.
Like I'm from Tel Aviv,
that's a good start.
And yeah, I studied 2D animation.
And in my first few years
I've worked in Israel,
just like in the industry
essentially gaining experience
in the field itself,
I was always that where
the spirit of entrepreneurship
was always there
is that I did always
want to do my own thing.
If anything, I think I can safely say
that I've been very opinionated
about my taste,
about how I think things should work,
whether on an industry level
or even in a granular narrative level.
And that really drove me forward.
Because one of my goals was
I realized, okay,
if I'm going to stay in Israel, sure,
I'll be able to continue working
but it's never going
to take me one step forward,
or one step beyond.
I always wanted to get more into--
The glass ceiling.
Exactly.
Kind of the glass ceiling of just,
you know, being outside of where
real entertainment kind of comes from
which is Los Angeles,
where I live in today.
And I knew that
I kind of had to be here
to really get things going.
Especially because a lot of my interest
was in developing original IP.
Now, another really bizarre thing,
or I don't know if it's that bizarre,
I'm a big fan of everything I like.
Like, I wear it on myself, like armor.
And I've always been a video game fan.
I also worked
as a videogame journalist
early on in my career,
ended up really drawing me back and forth
between work on software,
whether it's like educational
or game development, to TV animation.
So, I've always
kind of skipped between the two.
I moved to the States
at around 10 years ago.
And I did my master's here
and then moved to California
because I was like,
all right, if I want
to work in animation,
if I want to work in entertainment,
this is the place.
You've got to be here.
And fun fact, before you moved to the US,
you actually helped me compete
in a doodle for Google competition
for I think like,
Israel's 60th anniversary.
And so, thank you
for taking the time to spend with
you know, my eight year old self.
I was amazed
that you remember that.
Of course I remember, because
I sent it in, and I don't know
if you even know,
I sent it as if I did it.
Totally fine.
I just sat next to you while you did it.
You have just documented
your crime, sir.
Exactly.
Amit, before we continue,
you're mentioning the animation space.
Graphic design space.
I know nothing about this.
Give me the three-minute crash course,
what is the animation space?
What is the supply chain look like?
What does an animator even do
in their day to day life?
That is a fantastic question,
and it's multilayered.
And it actually transitions really nicely
into how I started
my company, PopBase
with Lisa and Richard.
Perfect.
So basically, like, as an animator,
even though you are essentially
the craftsperson making the show
whether it's 3D animation
or 2D animation,
you are the one moving the character.
Animation is in the end, motion.
It's motion graphics.
It's more specifically,
let's say character based motion graphics
is the best way to kind of define it,
as opposed to just standard
like motion graphics
that are more graphic design based.
And in the end of the day,
this is a massive, massive industry
that is cross generational,
that's dealing with a lot
of creative IPs.
I think one of the things
that I've seen both fascinates
the tech industry
and also really confused
is A, entertainment seems to have
a really massive blind spot
when it comes down
to integrating technology, right,
Into its pipelines.
These are actually really old
programming pipelines.
As an animator, you come in
and you work within the studio system,
right?
So, by the time that you come in,
the process has already been through
you know, a show has been pitched.
That's your concept.
The show has been developed
and there are multiple steps
in the process
whether it went through a network
or studio system.
It actually gets incredibly complicated.
And then by the end of it,
when it actually gets greenlight
into production,
you're starting with pre-production.
You're bringing in your screenwriters,
then you're bringing in
your storyboard artist, your designers.
At some point,
while production is already running,
you have a channel
that it's going to be on
or you know what your distribution is.
At that point, the animator comes in,
you already have all
of your guidelines, right?
You're part of an animation team.
You're usually working hand to hand
with pre-production and post-production.
In the end,
the show appears on television.
That's as simple as that.
Right.
So, animators in many ways
are as creative as they are,
they are a cog in the machine
where the top of the hierarchy
are always the networks
because they are primarily
distribution channels.
But many times, not always,
they're also the IP owners.
So, when you think of
cross generational properties
like Star Wars, for example, right,
this is an intellectual property.
And once again, intellectual property
in the world of tech,
and I've seen this multiple times
when talking to because VCs,
it means something very different.
So, they're thinking of technological
intellectual property.
And when you're talking
about intellectual property in Hollywood,
very often or more often than not,
you are referring to something like
Star Wars, Spider-Man.
Like you're talking about
narrative driven intellectual properties.
And the amazing thing
about those intellectual properties
is that they very rarely,
if at all become irrelevant.
And that's what I mean
by cross generational.
And you can see
like Hollywood marketing
is very aware of that.
So, they make sure, now we're going
to create the Star Wars
for the younger generation.
Right.
And this goes all the way back
to even fairy tales. Right?
Stuff that is currently public domain.
Because stories are,
or good storytelling is immortal. Right?
So, in many ways,
if your intellectual property is a story
and it has characters,
and it's defined
by those certain parameters,
as long as you own it,
it is potentially immortal.
And it could be applied to games,
to television, to really any form
of entertainment.
And that's where the licensing business
in Hollywood comes from.
You're a developer,
you don't have
your own intellectual property,
but you say,
"Hey, you know what?
If I have the license for Spider-Man,
I can make an Amazing Spider-Man game
and I can monetize
the living hell out of it."
Well, if you have enough capital
to basically give to at this point,
Disney to license out the IP
and they approve it,
now you get to monetize
on their intellectual property.
Which means,
they get part of the revenue,
you get part of the revenue.
Still a standard licensing model.
But once again,
the thinking is really
all around the narrative.
Right?
Interesting.
Yeah, that's how they define
the intellectual property
that's of the highest value in Hollywood.
For me, I came from again,
from animation to IP development.
I started pitching
original IPs to networks.
I started selling and optioning shows
to TV networks
and getting in front of that pipeline.
And when you're there,
you get to see
A, what they're looking for;
and B, also what they're thinking about
in terms of how to immortalize
their own brands.
Because if you think of a TV network,
they can have like
a lot of different TV shows.
But in the end, they are trying,
if they're a good brand,
they're trying to define themselves.
Like we are the branded mix of
shows of this kind.
We're telling these kinds of stories.
We have a style, we have a,
Disney has been teaching everybody
how to do that
while incorporating other brands
underneath its umbrella.
Right?
They are basically the crown jewel
of the industry in that regard.
Both the crown jewel and the Death Star.
Right?
So, you can define it
whichever way you want.
But when we looked at that
we realized that one of the weaknesses,
and that goes all the way back to
Hollywood's weakness, like when it comes
to integrating new pipelines
or technology pipelines is that
everything is really siloed.
It is an incredibly siloed industry.
Their relationship,
their fascination with the industry
of like video games,
which is one of the fastest growing,
like branches of entertainment
currently out there,
has been, it kind of goes both ways
with the video game industry
obviously having an interest
in Hollywood's big IPs,
because that's what inspired a lot
of video game developers
to create what they're doing.
But also, Hollywood's like
fascination with anything that is
a little bit more sci-fi,
this is interactively,
know that it's the future
but they're also afraid of it
because they don't fully understand it.
And they don't know how to handle it.
Which was why a lot
of big businesses like
Universal and Disney,
even recently said that,
"We're not going to try
and develop our own things anymore.
We're just going to go
into a licensing model.
So, if you want to make games
based on our IPs,
just go right ahead."
I didn't know all this.
It's so interesting.
So, there's, and again,
this has been evolving over the years.
And it's been going back and forth.
Like if you think of Disney as an entity,
their department of Disney Interactive
has shut down and reopened about
like three or four times
in the last 10 to 15 years.
That's how fast this is moving
of how they just [--]
their new agenda is.
But what was very clear to us is that,
as a society
and I don't think that this is
a controversial statement
at this point,
we have a communication problem.
Right?
And it's whether you're trying
to educate people,
whether you're trying to entertain them,
whether you're trying to market to them,
or if you're just trying
to explain to people
that the world isn't flat
in the year 2020, for some reason.
You essentially have to have
three key elements
in order to really cut
through the noise right now.
You need to have
the long and short form storytelling,
abilities of essentially Hollywood,
of shows of Netflix,
of streaming media.
You need to have the interactivity
of video games
because that really enhances
knowledge retention.
And of course,
when you look at the younger generation,
this is one of the main forms
of communication they consume
in multiple different ways.
And you also need to have,
and this is really key,
you need to have the flexibility
and the speed of response
of social media. Right?
Yes.
A tweet comes out and exposes itself
to so many people,
so much faster than an entity,
even as powerful as Disney can respond.
Right?
So, it's so much easier
to get bad information out there
and much, much faster
than getting good vetted information
that is controlled by you
to your audience.
And part of it is just that pipeline.
If you think about creating
an animated show, right?
And this is where
my experience comes in in this company.
Because our entire agenda
and what our technology does
is take those three things. Right?
The fast, flexibility,
and response time of social media,
basically social media
marketing practices,
interactivity of video games
and the ability to tell
an ongoing linear story
take this three things,
kills them in one stone
and essentially build an infrastructure
that puts them all through one ecosystem.
Which is incredibly powerful
and has taken us years
to actually develop something
that can work.
But the idea is really to be able
to create a form of communication
that is sustainable,
that is future proof.
And we just believe that
it's kind of inevitable. Right?
I have to say, Amit,
you know, you were talking about
you know, PopBase
and the journey
that you've gone through.
And I have to say
that I've seen the product
and the way that you're describing it
as a communication tool
and future proof,
and that whole vertical
of this integrated communication that,
you know, is not really understandable
for somebody coming from, you know,
both from a different generation,
even I'm considering myself
as an older generation for this.
Because, you know,
I'm getting and producing information
very differently in the way that,
for example, my nieces do.
Right.
But I think the way you're doing
with PopBase is really fascinating.
And I'd love for you
to share with me a little bit about
what you're tangibly doing?
What is PopBase?
What is the technology
that you're building?
And what is the future
that you envision
with PopBase as an integral part
of every kid's, I guess daily routine,
as they go through learning
and developing habits?
That's a fantastic question.
So, let me try and give you
the aspirational part of the picture
that will maybe help illustrate
what it is we're aiming for.
So, if you can imagine,
let's say, a Netflix cartoon
and animated show,
they're also plays like
an open world video game,
like a Zelda, World of Warcraft,
but has the ability to update its content
and be as responsive
as a social media brand.
That's essentially the technology
that PopBase built.
It is a CMS.
So, it's a web portal
that allows us to control a creative IP
within an ecosystem on any screen.
Now, I'll illustrate that for you.
Right.
So, our go to market strategy right now,
we're basically,
we built this technology.
We're like, we know this works.
We know this is fantastic.
We know we can drive these
incredibly immersive
story driven experiences
and really just control
a virtual world
through a live ops dashboard
in a way that isn't loose.
And what I mean by isn't loose,
it's not a creator platform.
Which is what a lot of the focus
of let's say, social media companies
have been currently like.
How do we make sure that anyone
can just tell any story.
Okay, but that is usually not the tool
that a large brand, let's say,
like Disney can use
in the same extent.
Right?
Sure, they can distribute stuff
on YouTube, now you're
on the same playing field
as everybody else.
It doesn't really
immerse you in the world,
it doesn't allow you
to control the whole thing.
You're still relying
on a separate ecosystem.
So, what we're doing is
that we're launching through
the wellness market. Right?
Which is a full of white space.
It's got like $575 billion
market right now
where most of the apps
that kids are given
are either mini games,
or they're kind of like
they have the Fitbit approach
of like I'm giving you
an interactive task list
that's gamefied.
But what is the problem?
I mean, what is the problem
of the wellness space?
Why is there so much money
that is being poured in?
You know, this is an extraordinary amount
of money that any startup
would love to say they're in,
a multi $100 billion space.
I would never imagine that
the wellness communication space
is that big.
What's going on there?
Look at where we live right now.
The times of covid.
And this is exactly
the point of why we're saying
we have a communication problem.
Right?
Where just the idea of teaching people,
"Hey, wear a mask when you go outside
because this is what happened.
Wash your hands."
Right?
Basic hygiene, basic safety.
Things that you think people should know
or should learn through schools
or should learn through, really anywhere.
But right now, when somebody like
if the FDA tweets something
and if the president tweets something
and if a troll tweets something,
it's flat.
It's the same amount of noise.
Right?
It's really hard for people
to source out what's real
and what's not.
They need something trusted.
Now for us, we're saying,
we're trying to get
to a generation that's early.
Like our go to market focus is
on children that are ages four to six.
And part of the idea is, well,
this is a generation that's growing
watching Netflix, scrubbing on Tiktok,
playing video games like Fortnight.
You can't give them interactive test
with apps or give them pamphlets
and expect them like, yeah,
they're going to retain this information.
If the teacher comes in and goes, like,
"Wash your hands, kids."
They're going to go,
"Hmmn, okay."
Who cares, right?
You can't do that.
But we come from entertainment.
And we know
that one of the most powerful things
you can do is
it has to come from intrinsic motivation.
Right?
So, you have to want
to engage with something
and learn from it.
So many people talk about how,
you know, a certain, let's say,
movie has made them feel something
or give them the power
to apply what they've learned from it.
It sounds kind of silly,
but it really isn't.
These are stories that inspire you.
And we want to create
an immersive experience
that is essentially speaking
their language because it's quick,
it's responsive, it's immersive,
it feels like you're going
into a magical world.
You don't know you're there to learn it.
It's more like Dora the Explorer,
or Sesame Street.
When you as a kid watch Sesame Street,
you don't think you're watching
something educational.
As an adult you go,
"Oh, okay, the count,
it's teaching me how to. Oh, I see."
But you don't think of that as a kid
because you're too busy
being in within the world
that entertained.
We're saying,
we're creating a virtual world
where every feature is something
we can control
and change on a minute,
like on a moment's notice,
through our dashboard
in order to be able to respond
to how people behave with it.
In order to actually
talk directly to our audience
without even knowing
who each person is.
You think of Dora the Explorer.
They always have these segments
where you know,
and it's very sweet
and I get where it's coming from,
but it's also kind of awkward
that Dora kind of turns to the camera
and goes like,
"Well, kids, what do you think?"
Right.
Blank stare and I'm like...
You assume that they respond.
You pilot it, but you can't really
track something like that.
We're actually telling kids,
"No, you need to respond
and we'll know it." Right?
You're actually speaking
to the character
I think that I have to say, Amit,
one of the things
that I have to mention here,
because I think, you know,
on one hand creating content
that is interactive
and is producing the same effect
and it's incredible.
But building an infrastructure
that allows others to come
and modify that content
to fit their own specific needs, right,
every school wants to tell
their story a little bit different.
Every place that needs to teach
about how to deal with an earthquake
needs to learn a little bit
of a different situation,
different communication, you know.
We're looking at a globalized world.
We're still a million different cultures.
You know, even within the US,
we have different cultures
and different ways of communication.
And having a team of the animators,
building one product
with one communication
that targets all,
it just doesn't work,
especially not for kids.
And I think that what you're doing
with PopBase beyond
the actual, you know,
messaging of one game,
but actually building the infrastructure
that allows other creators to go
and modify that,
I think that's really
the innovative part here
that I as a technologist
and as a startup enthusiast,
I'm really excited about.
Yeah. Thank you.
And the interesting thing
is the way that we're thinking
about it, and again,
we'll see where
the market actually takes us.
But right now,
the way that we're launching
is that we're launching
our own original IP.
Because once again,
we're doing this kind of great value,
and we get to gather
our own team of experts
to say, we have a show runner,
an actual Hollywood show runner.
Like he's going
to help us dictate the content.
He's not going to rely on their knowledge.
But like you said,
he's going to work with schools,
he's going to work with hospitals
and essentially tell them like,
"A segment of our audience,
we want to give them this information.
Can we give this just to?"
Absolutely.
This system allows you to do that.
It allows you
to also distribute it publicly.
Now, what it also allows to do,
and that's what we're really hoping,
because that's the, let's say,
Woodland Mystery is the product
that we're launching on the system
as you know, it's a railway system.
And this is the first product
we've kind of tossing on it
because, again,
area full of white space,
it's a good way to break
into the market.
But what we're saying is,
okay, on one hand you can have
the $100 million business
of Woodland Mysterie's does really well.
And now, the kids
are growing out of it,
make your new IP. Right?
Make another one for kids
five to eight.
Make another one so kids grow up.
It's great.
We will be delighted.
That's like having
your own proprietary tool
that gives you that advantage.
The other thing you touched on,
that's the multibillion dollar business.
Right?
And it's something
that we're optimizing for,
which is the minute you put it out,
there are tool, doesn't only solve
the communication problem,
it's also it's a pipeline tool
that comes from, again,
thinking of animation.
Our founding team comes from,
I come from television.
My CEO and CTO both come
from a long, long history
of video game development,
on both engineering
and the technical art side.
And that's where we really combine
our thinking with.
Like this is how Hollywood handles things
and this is how video games
handle things.
Just as a side note, video game,
the video game industry
has been so far ahead
on so many technologies.
And I think now
the tech world is starting
to catch up to it
because they're going like,
"Oh, my God,
why is this so successful?
How are they doing these things?"
In terms of R&D,
they are so far ahead,
you have no idea.
Like, I encourage you to look more
and more into the video game industry.
Because a lot of the tech companies
right now that are considered disruptive
really seem to them like primitive,
at this point. Right?
So, when you look at all of these pipelines,
we're essentially saying,
and this is an interesting
piece of information regardless,
but when you look at an animation show,
like a show like on Cartoon Network
on Adult Swim, it takes the network
about anywhere between 500 to $700,000
per episode to produce.
And it takes a very long time.
You think of the length
of a season on Netflix, it's like
eight episodes per season.
The traditional format
is more like 11 minutes,
20 episodes per season.
And it takes years
from when you actually
start pre-production to when you edit.
And even the production
of an episode itself takes months.
We essentially built a tool
that allows us
to distribute the same length
like a half hour, fully interactive,
fully immersive piece of content
in episode with a team of like
five to six people in two weeks.
So, going back
to what this model does,
if we put it out there
and it gets very quickly validated,
our hope is someone like a Disney,
like a Cartoon Network,
which we have worked with before,
looks at this and goes,
"Wait a minute, you've done what?"
"Can I use that?"
Can I essentially use
my own intellectual property
to communicate my message?
It could be purely entertainment,
it could be education,
but I want to do this.
There you go.
Here's our API,
Here are our developer tools.
And here's all the documentation.
Now, you have the power
to do the same thing.
And that's what we're really hoping for
and that's what we're optimizing
the entire business around.
But, you know, it's a journey.
Amit, wonderful.
And you know, beyond everything,
beyond the technology
and animation industry,
I think that the fact that
what you're working on really
at the end of the day,
it's in the wellness space.
And the positive impact
it's going to have
the butterfly effect
that it's going to have
is just tremendous.
That's what really
I'm excited about from the sidelines.
But it's a really amazing job.
And it's really, really inspiring
to get to know these new industries
and these new passions.
And watching somebody growing up
with a certain passion
and following it through,
both relocating
and moving through different journeys,
but now working on PopBase
for quite some time now
and being so passionate about it,
honestly, that's one
of the most inspiring things here.
Before we leave, I have to ask you
for the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay. I would say determined,
I would say a direct,
I would say loud.
And you can interpret that
in any way you want.
I love all of those.
Amit, thank you so, so much.
Best of luck with PopBase.
And I can't wait to see
where this thing is going.
Thank you.